I think we start off with the the watch
first of all pre-order of course
starting today mixed reviews out there
something is just a gimmick what's your
view well you know I think it's one of
those devices that out of the gate it's
not a slam dunk I've used the device
it's takes a little bit of getting used
to and I think we haven't yet seen the
killer application that it's going to
make the apple watch a must-have and
until that application surfaces I think
it you know it'll be a little bit
rougher ride for Apple than some people
anticipated well how does it compare in
your view to them with you know the
other companies which already launched
watches I mean we've already seen
something with its gear out yeah I will
say that you know the Apple watch feels
very much like a version one device but
in its defense it is by far the
best-looking v1 versus anybody out there
right now so you know we've talked a
little bit about Samsung they've they've
thrown a handful of units out into the
market and you know those have not
resonated with people they've really
been tech first and you know something
people want to wear second so I do think
Apple has a leg up in terms of fit and
finish and the quality of the object
itself yeah it slow burn people's you
know didn't like the iPad when it came
out it got fairly well I can I saved
poor reviews didn't it Tom but that was
a slow burn wasn't it certainly and
maybe v1 is not the best time to be
buying a product like this now I think
there's some truth to that and I think
the the ipad again was one of those
devices that Apple put out in the market
and they told people you need this but a
lot of people looked at it and said hey
is that just a big ipod touch and it
wasn't until they honed it or a friend
of there there's owned it and they used
it for a while when they began to figure
out okay this is how it fits into my
life let's move on to the other product
product launch today and that is of
course the galaxy s6 from samson now
they're hoping this phone turns things
around
for them against the iphone will it how
good a device is it and well you know
how what does Samson have to do in order
to get back in claw back market share
yeah i think it's a it's a bold move by
Samsung I think you could make the
argument that they played it safe in the
last couple iterations of their flagship
phone and with the s6 and the F s6 edge
they're really pushing forward on some
things that only Samsung can do which is
to say particularly on the edge there's
only a handful of companies in the world
that can create a display like that and
so what Samsung is trying to do with
that product i think is create make it
more difficult for particularly the
chinese vendors that have been taking
some of their market share to do a
carbon copy of what they've created in
the s6 edge so i think i think it's a
move in the right direction but it will
be challenging the thing is they're
using this android operating system and
you know it seems that really the only
serious contender to that is the Apple
operating system where everybody else is
using Android virtually aren't they yeah
and that's that's one of the challenges
that I think Samsung faces and if
Samsung doesn't regain its footing
whoever replaces them i think ends up
facing a very similar situation is which
is that nobody owns the platform google
owns the platform and so it's very hard
for the company even a company the size
of samsung to create a differentiated
experience on a samsung phone so it's
very easy for example for someone to own
a galaxy s3 and then two years later
move over to an HTC one for example
because they like the form factor better
because the the Android experience is
essentially the same till I was reading
your research note and you were saying a
lot will depend on what happens in the
future with some of the seeds as you put
it being planted by Sampson right now
what are those seeds and how will they
bear fruit well they've they have spent
a fair amount of time and effort trying
to grow an install base of programmers
who will create the right apps that
would run specifically on samsung either
Android devices or their own Tizen
operating system so they have been
trying to become more of a software
company you know the other thing that I
think is interesting is just like Apple
has launched Apple pay Samsung is
getting into the pay business as well
and so they're trying to create more
points of stickiness so that it's not so
easy to move off of a Samsung device and
onto another Android device because
their software their services there's
features that you can only find on a
samsung device say you won't find on
another yeah you're talking about of
course that acquisition of Luke pay now
just living to this partnership that got
with Microsoft how did they move that
forward yeah I think that's an
interesting point and I think it speaks
to the position that both of those
companies are in Microsoft's new CEO I
think has got that company moving in the
right direction and they become very
keenly aware of the fact that their
success is going to be driven by getting
on to other successful platforms and
holding office for example off of
Android and iOS wasn't really serving
Microsoft in the end and now that
they've announced this partnership with
Samsung they're clearly going to get
their software and services onto a big
platform and I think it net net is good
for both Samsung and Microsoft